数が
だああああ
入ってくる新人に来たんですけどもの角がないんですねえ味を静岡にあった服とか前
東京で借りてた家にあった軽めの側がいた持つこんなんですけどまだ全然角がない声が
日々次非常に困ってるしなんかせっかくコーナー素敵なお部屋なんであのう
[音楽]
ブービーフェイスのある方に
カークとかあんたらもうマネーんですよこれ
しれないんですよヒーロー家具か電動何にもないんですよで殺さ天丼にょけどもうロス
っっにしてほしいということにちょっとあるかと思います
me
反対わけで本日はインテリアコーディネータ仏事さんに思っていただいておりますけど
よろしくお願いします
ん
インテリアコーディネータという
[音楽]
ペリーがあったんですよ
ええええええ
貼っます
[音楽]
そうなんですよ
本当にクールとか全く追えてないので気
もの頃ずっとと相談しながら素敵なお部屋にしていただけると嬉しいのね
[音楽]
今日は寄せています
超選手は何をするんですか
today
[音楽]
なることですねどんなお部屋
思っています
はいぜひの
なるほどですねえっとぉ
この部屋わーん
撮影に整体でよく
普通のたいですね
ん
ここでも作っています
そこでなくてもいいと思うんですよ
ここは寝室にしたいですね
良いベッドで見たいんだ
ここにでも着れると期待した
暗い子は嬉しいですね
太陽違いなんです経済ん
有機ライていますこの外にもすごい
うん
非常に分
いいですねそれはつければと思います
[音楽]
あな
女もずれ込むようですね
お願いしまーすいっ
塩をこうでないと思います
today
me
バッファローと選手が助かりましたよはいはいもうちょっと君が代は持った
水が入らん2
ああああああ
不全 ps 3
ビッドでも僕てボラカイの好きです
他の人もそう姉のような場所だったです
[音楽]
arms
543どんなもんなんですかね
版的にはどれございます
[音楽]
なるほどですね
1000万デー
[音楽]
a 全霊でどうせだったらしっかりしようと思っているんです
鑑定で結構かかりそうん
何もなかった部屋から1か月がたちましたコーディネーターだと
お部屋のコーディネートがあっ
終わりました
コーディネート者が1000万7室やですけども
ちょっと覚えていっ200万円のコーディネートでございます
[音楽]
ああお塩というわけで僕も本当に何も知らないんですよ
カッコ見込みとがいろいろ込めて1か月かかって一回使ってそのインテリア角度を集め
てもらって
運び込みに1週間かかってるんで僕は1週間この辺に入れなかったわけなんですけども
それでは何か別の部屋とかに住んでたんですよね早速
インテリアコーディネーターです
すべてをお任せして線200万円の4
[音楽]
いきましょうどっから行こうかねチームも変わってたって聞いたんでまずはキッチン
から見てみましょう
いきます
[音楽]
はっはっは
t 増子だと映像子がある
直物はセニエめっちゃいい感じにまとまってますね
ゴミ箱でしょうねこれは
[音楽]
継母えーなにこれなにこれなにこれ知らないの吠えてるんだけどプーすぐ
を冷蔵庫だ行った東京に落ち持ってるんですね冷蔵庫買ったことないんですよねうん
かわいいこれもやってくれたのクリスマスだもんねー
こうキッチン完璧でても料理できるようになってますありがとうございましたますよ
こっちメインの部屋なんですね
bb がちょっと最後にしましょう寝室も変わった points と見てみようと
思います
でも選出いきます
[音楽]
はい yeah
ざーわーちょっとっちゃえばぬわぁ
てりゃー
熱ドレスはたメロンが滅茶苦茶怒ってんだけど何これ何これ
いやいやいやめっちゃオシャレやんけすごい
何から青俳外国の本じゃなくてこれはですね
正面を見たことないんですね
合意上野これがもう何かわけわかんないねやすごーいですは tv版してもう超大進化
しておりますねー
た before after すごいよな枝が落ちた比べ物にならんくらいってが
すごいわ
選んだあんまりじゃないんですけどめちゃくちゃオシャレになってるんだきっと光っ
てるし
うわぁ命名クリスマ
なっています
5位これはか
どうしたこんなにかけで親って変わるんですね
病院をそしてリビングですこっちの部屋はもう撮影ところするつもりなんで結構あの
厳し目に見ますよでも早速開けてみましょう
和姦
[音楽]
ん
ステッカーですうわぁ強いどういうつける場所が版ないと思う
すごいすごいすごいすごい堀田家近く断っている
[音楽]
はっはっは
ふぅ
ちょっとあるほんといくら俺ん家だった切ってこれいやーもうソファーも壁もすごい
なぁ
チクチクしてんじゃねぇこれ本当につくづく知ってないのかね近未来がちゃんと出て
ますねなにこれ
金で出てるしこれ
牛田車2打はなんか数でポスターとかも全部を探すこんな会社のじゃんこれ
この高いんだろうなんでもいやすごい1200なってからこうなっちゃうのか言って
ああ
じゃあ創造的にし9いっしょおかっこいいねこちらや仕切りが付いてるんでこんなかも
多分違う気がするんですよねいきます
うわぁ
かわいい
えっ金色大切な回れない棒じゃないか各鏡
この山をしっかりますしねーなにこのかわいい空間
大宮すごいわ
言葉を失うな1200万円でこんなゲームを使うあるんですねちょっと
インテリアコーディネーターさんに話し聞いてみましょういいはいっ
たあるほどです線
ありなものではございません
はぁで回転しますよね
ちっ
俺のセラない文房がこれも匂いがう
すごくいい香りです
これを燃えてるんですか abd だけでかっこいい
この台ももカッコイイですよそうなんですよ
7分はい
かっこいいですありがとうございますこの大は何円くらいですか
よろしいですねああそうなんだタカツ業進出ですかね
二人で寝るよーみたいな感じるからネット分
インサイ無難で打って
ゆったりいって
すごい本当に切りせないんですよ
てしまうと触っていい
デザイナーさんの
壁紙なんですけど本当にパーンとみたいなか
いやおしゃべですわ
はいあっこっこれですね可愛いぞ気軽にものを受けないですもう
2節んそうですね早寝しますいい色でした
ブレイディ
は月なるともう来さんの
カラーう
節制塩ねこんな臍以下質疑見たことにです
に入りたいと彼知らせまた
でダムが
ダルほど素晴らしいでしょあいすけでみたいなのも好きです
いやーすごい汗で木としたらちょっと思いますよ
こちらがう
出会いありがとうございますつづく
ええええ
投稿ちゃんと入る大きさにしたかってね私に良い日の比較の線
これってくださいいきますよ
こういうのですね
かわいいおそらく l ですよね
まあわかりやすいですねいろいろ充電するものがあるじゃないですか
うん
ノッポくらい版有り事言ってんですね
[音楽]
充電た
うわぁそして冷蔵庫感動しましたこれちょっと
いやーすごかったですねにっ
いきだるまを立てる本当ですかキャッチャーせませんそれを食べますねもう下手を
fear すごいっすありがとうございますもう良いを注ぎか
リビングということだいやーすごかったですも
これねー
いやー
ルっ子はいーやー
これも区
3日に乗ったんですよ
本に載ってみてくださいといううやでを脱ぐとそれだ
いや全然でも上なに感じてもらおうと思ったんですよなぁうーん
ん
もうちょっとプリピっページのうん
やばいこの歯医者のホンキって感じですね
これはすごいですねー
[音楽]
に出るんですかこれ本当な
客さんに来たらここでうすごい成功と黄色のこれは
[音楽]
すごいいびつな形が決められやすいえええ
そしてこの位数
[音楽]
言えません近未来ですよね歩きがすごいですね絶対見て思ったの
ねこれは行って
前の声がはみ出てるんですけどこれ
調整にとらわれないデザインですねてこの造りですね
まったく大理石にが寮に入る大できるぞ
yes う
してこれは一切一家リア
アート
これいってますふーん
これ僕なんかを制圧したほうがいいですね
頑張りますこっちもすごいですねー
にゃありがとうございます1種が金融で先制
それをお互いにで俯瞰
1日のみに使ってみたで一本取れそうな
入ったん
[音楽]
一人からな感じん
確かにそしてこんな素敵なツリーまで先生ありがとうございます
これ自分へのクリスマスプレゼントだなぁもう
[音楽]
ありがとうございましたいやーすばらしいですも本当にありがとうございます
数字で自信がありません先生っ線100万円の高齢者なんですけど一番高かったトップ
スリックどんな感じですかね
[音楽]
google データで200万ぐらいん
ベッドとなって取り組みますか別途向け来たナースっ
[音楽]
寝る場所って人生の1/3を過ごすって言われてるから
大事ですよ
[音楽]
持ってるぜええ
太陽カ月かける訳あって
すいません特急であれどね無事クリスマスにこんな感じでして本当に良かったです
思った
これを追った感じがなかったんだよ本当にはもう
先生にお任せしていたんでインパクターすごかったんですごい満足してます
いやいや全然のずまた機会があったら持って写ってください
もう before after こんな感じですはい
全然違いますねもうというわけで東京の心境
線200万円布袋か
ca 4
[音楽]
あっはっは
re
[音楽]
ウォーカーし